NARRATOR: The government
They've spent the last 40 years
fighting to get them back.
From 1976 to 1983,
Argentina fell
under a military dictatorship.
During this time,
government death squads
hunted down anyone suspected
of political dissidence.
Up to 30,000 people disappeared.
Among them were pregnant women.
The mothers were kept
alive until giving
birth, after they were killed.
Their orphaned newborns
were given to couples
who supported the government.
It is estimated that 500
newborns were kidnapped
in this way, but the
grandmothers of the lost
children refused to give up.
Mothers and grandmothers of the
disappeared banded together--
boldly standing up
to the government
by marching in silent
protest every Thursday
around the Plaza de Mayo--
earning the title
Abuelas de Plaza de Mayo.
After the regime fell in
1983, they began their search.
The grandmothers became
their own detectives.
By 1987, they had found
39 of the lost children,
but hundreds were still missing.
So they turned to an emerging
science in mitochondrial DNA,
which could match individual
children with women who might
be their maternal grandmothers.
But they still needed
samples from the taken.
So, in 1997, they
invited anyone who
was uncertain about their
identity to come forward.
Many did.
Helping bring the
number of lost children
found to more than 120.
[music playing]
[speaking spanish]
The abuelas are now a recognized
human rights organization.
They have received multiple
nominations for the Nobel Peace
Prize, and remain
dedicated to rebuilding
families and restoring
justice until all the lost
have been found.
WOMAN: March on, celebrating
women who changed the world.